this movie is directed by Woody Allen
the guy who voiced an aunt in the film
ants I think he's done some other things
too blue Jasmine as I said is directed
by Woody Allen and stars Kate Blanchet
Alec Baldwin Peter Sarsgaard and really
a giant cast filled with very talented
people in this movie Cate Blanchet plays
a woman who's dealing with a divorce
who's dealing with some serious social
issues and some serious mental issues as
well she's trying to pick up the pieces
of her life she's moving in with her
sister who isn't extremely well off well
she was very used to being well off with
her former husband played by Alec
Baldwin we see their life in various
scenes that you could call flashbacks
but they're not really flashbacks
because of the way Woody Allen tells
this story and we learned that she used
to have a very privileged life but that
life has kind of turned into a lie and
because of that she's kind of gone
insane for me Woody Allen is kind of hit
and miss he's made some excellent films
I love match point I think match points
one of his best films one of his more
recent films midnight in Paris was
fantastic he's obviously made many
classic films over the years but he does
have some films along the way they're
just like yeah that could have been
better blue jasmine is not one of those
films this is actually one of his best
films in my opinion I really thought
this movie was fantastic largely because
of a stand out 100% oscar-worthy
performance by Cate Blanchett this is
the best performance I've seen from an
actress all year she was absolutely
terrific in this movie her character
felt so real and I didn't see Cate
Blanchett after a while I mean yes in my
head I was going man she's doing a
really good job but her character was a
character to me I didn't see the actress
anymore which is the best compliment I
can possibly give to an actress or an
actor when you start thinking of that
person as that character I mean that's
it she did it I really like the way
Woody Allen told the story to because
there isn't a hint that you are now
going to see a scene in the past you
know oftentimes in movies a director
will show a mirage or a blurred image
lulululu and now we're in the past
nothing like that in this movie you'll
see Cate Blanchett in the present and in
the very next scene she's standing with
Alec Baldwin you're like what oh this is
in the past you'll understand it really
quickly which scenes are in the past and
the present and I really like the way
Woody Allen did that because he did it
in a way that respects the audience he's
not going to assume that the audience
requires a linear story and he told it
in a nonlinear way in a way that I think
a few audience members in my theater
were like wait oh is he and I think cuz
I was definitely the youngest person in
this movie for sure I was like everyone
else was like 60 and above and I heard a
few people going like what is that the
past now what's that now
well really everyone in the film did a
really terrific job Bobby Cannavale
Cannavale II not sure how to say that he
was great in the movie
Woody Allen made this movie look
terrific the San Francisco Coast is
really beautiful in this movie it almost
looked like a foreign country at times
and I was really impressed with the look
and feel the film but Kate Blanchet is
just so riveting in this movie her
performance is heartbreaking it's really
entrancing and you just watch her and
you're like my word that is an actress
on the top of her game I mean it really
seemed like certain shots Woody Allen
was like I'm just gonna keep this take
forever and just let it run without
cutting because she's doing such a good
job
I like the journey of her character even
though her character is pretty
despicable and you start to think man
this is a messed up woman I never
stopped liking watching her because she
was so fascinating as a character and
Blanchette played her so well I think
Woody Allen fans will love this movie
because I wouldn't say that I'm like a
humongous fan of him because he is a
little bit inconsistent regards to his
films quality but when he does have a
hit he hits it out of the park and blue
jasmine was really great I'm gonna give
it an A - I suggest seeing it if you are
a fan of art films or independent films
or just a good performances definitely
check it out it's one of the better
movies that I've seen this summer so
guys thanks very much for watching and
if you like this you can click right
here and get stuck mine eyes